there are so many similarities between
the two elections that the one can
hardly remember them all one of the
reasons I became interested in Obama a
long time ago was I heard too many
people saying but he had lost his chance
to be President the day he was born
black in America just as in 1960 they
were saying John F Kennedy had lost his
chance to be President the day he was
baptized Catholic in America in 1960
they were saying John F Kennedy who was
39 in a freshman senator when he first
began exploring the possibility of the
presidency that was back in 1957 that he
was too young inexperienced and then I
began reading that they were saying that
Barack Obama who is an old geezer
compared to at 46 compared to Kennedy at
39 and Obama also is in his yes he's
also in his first term as United States
Senator they say he's too inexperienced
well if they want experience we could
probably drag out Cheney and Rumsfeld
again they have a lot of experience but
as Kennedy said when in 1960 when
Richard Nixon the Vice President of the
United States who had a long career in
Congress before he became vice president
of the United States
he said Kennedy it was too inexperienced
and it was an amateur well as Kennedy
pointed out experiences like the
taillights on a boat shows where you've
ended but not where you're going and
and I even liked all Joe Kennedy's
comment and some congressman told him
tell Jack forgets those young kids like
soreness and he should get some campaign
consultants who have a lot of national
experience and the president's father
said experience hell they're all
experienced and losing well Obama like
Kennedy has judgment he's been able to
see the country from living abroad just
as Kennedy did as the ambassador's son
Obama is committed to peace which is why
he opposed the Iraq war before it
started at a time when mrs. Clinton and
the other establishment Democrats were
buying the bush propaganda hook line and
sinker that's that's why Obama and the
debates was the only candidate who said
yes he'd be willing to sit down and talk
with the leaders of countries that
didn't like us in Iran Syria or wherever
just as Kennedy was willing to
communicate with Khrushchev at the
darkest moments of the Cuban Missile
Crisis and that's how we were able to
resolve that crisis without a gun being
fired on
the United States so there are many many
parallels and Obama's ability to inspire
the young everywhere I've gone I've
campaigned so far in seven states for
Obama in each of those states I've found
young dedicated people in the field
often from other states often sleeping
on floors and the living rooms of
strangers often going without pay
because they recognize the importance of
change and Obama represents change
Kennedy reached out to those young
people also he inspired them volunteers
in the campaign
a year later became volunteers in the
Peace Corps and in the civil rights
movement the consumer movement
environmental movement those are the
same kind of people that Obama is
inspiring today so there are many
parallels I think it'll be close after
all Kennedy won by only one quarter of
one percent of the popular vote
fortunately margins in the popular vote
frequently expressed themselves in
larger margins and the electoral vote so
he had a comfortable electoral vote
majority but certainly the popular vote
was very thin because frankly there was
still beneath the surface a lot of
bigotry against a Roman Catholic
president in this country in 1960 and
sad to say there's still a lot of
bigotry under the surface against a
black president in this country so I
haven't the slightest doubt that a one
election and I think he will be elected
but I think it'll be close I think it'll
be a narrow margin but Kennedy said the
day after his election a margin of one
vote is still demanded